German generals blame the collapse of the
Hindenburg Line and severe French Flemish
front losses on the arrival of fresh American
troops on November 9 carnival gnome advocate
and two days later a delegation of German
civilian signs an armistice of submission
British general Hague and council president
commands all inspect German headquarters
near Paris as delegates from 27 nations
prepared to convene in Paris to draw up
a Treaty of Peace which is to end World
War one German delegates are housed at the
hotel reservoir for Darren fun Lesnar
had an important member of the group
as Dortch lens representatives and their
secretaries make their way to the peace
conference the calendar reads January 18 1919
principle topic of conversation among allied
representatives is United States President Woodrow
Wilson's proposed peace without victory under
which the German people would be given a decent
national post-war existence within the big four
England France Italy in the United States only
America backs Wilson with other leaders such as
Poland's premier Petrovski prepared to hear more
about the plan Wilson are routed the convention of
all is to succeed in writing into the peace
treaty the covenant of a League of Nations
Mattress I waiting delegates include
America's Charles Evans Hughes and
England's David Lloyd George it is June
28 1919 and today the treaty is to be
signed prior to the actual signing comes a
speech from Lloyd George whose thoughts on
reparations were completely in opposition to
President Wilson's the big for Wilson comma
so Lloyd George in Italy's Victoria Londo
and to the Hall of Mirrors at Versailles
inside the hall gotta get signed the document
with Wilson ill from overwork hoping that
his League of Nations will correct the
shortcomings he feels are in the treaty
the actual Treaty of Peace
signatures and seals are fixed
for the alive Nations and the
big four leave the hall as the flag
of peace lies high above Versailles